you know the part where you get through
the queue and you finally get to the
front of the queue
and and you get to ride next
you know that feeling
you know how exciting it is to be next
you know what's really cool
we're next we get to do this
Isn't that cool
here's the part where I tell you I am
definitely gonna post my slides online
and there aren't any so I'm not going to
post them online
but we're going to take a tour of
asp.net minimal apis we're going to
start with an asp.net 5 project upgrade
it to.net 7 and see all this cool
c-sharp 10 and 11 features that we get
to leverage in that process all live
coding the code is online right now so
you can grab the code from this URL up
on GitHub github.com Rob Rich slash
minimal apis asp.net all of the things
that we're going to do today it's online
right now achievement unlocked
so each of the steps that we'll do is a
separate folder so you can pop open that
folder and take a look at the things and
by the way uh I didn't push refresh here
um I updated a few things yesterday this
will be really cool
um if this URL is a little bit too far
you can head to Rob rich.org Rob
rich.org click on presentations here at
the top and here is minimal apis with
asp.net and a link straight to that code
so Rob rich.org may be an easier way to
get there and at that point then you can
grab the code
while we're here on robich.org let's
click on about me and see some of the
things that I've done recently I am a
developer advocate for Shoreline and
both Docker and Microsoft have given me
some awards as well easy give Camp is
really fun easy give Camp brings
volunteer developers together with
Charities to build free software we
start building software Friday after
work Sunday afternoon we deliver
completed software to the Charities
sleep is optional caffeine provided
if you're in Phoenix come join us for
the next AZ give camp or if you'd like a
gift Camp here in London or wherever you
came from where you wherever you
traveled from find me here at the event
hit me up on email Twitter or Mastodon
and let's get a givecamp in your
neighborhood too
some of the other things that I've done
I'm a friend of Redgate a pro
microservices in.net6 that was a lot of
fun to write I got to work with my
friend Sean and Matt on that I run a
user group in Utah and one in Arizona
and one of the things I'm particularly
proud of
I replied to a.net rocks podcast episode
they read my comments on the air and
they sent me a mug
so there's my claim to fame as my
coveted.net rocksmug and if you'd like
a.net rocks
Richard's talk this morning was amazing
though
so let's start with some interesting
things I've got a folder here it has
exactly one file in it let's open this
up in vs code I could have scaffolded it
out or typed out the Cs proj file but
basically it just says
I'm a.net website in this case it's dot
net seven it's a website and that's
pretty much all it says
so let's create a new file
program.cs oh thank you vs code yes it
creates this dot vs code folder that
gives us some interesting things for
debugging we'll nicely ignore that and
let's write a web server
VAR Builder equals
web application dot create Builder
uh yeah I'll pass in the command line
arguments that works
VAR app equals Builder dot build
app dot run that will start up my web
server what do I want my web server to
do
app.map get i'll map the home page to
this function and GitHub copilot has
seen me do this a little bit so let's
say new we'll give it a new object nope
not a task
message equals hello world
but
um in case somebody wants to pass in
a name I'll make that optional actually
and let's say hello
world or let's say hello name let's make
that a string like this and I'll even
give it an optional
NDC London
and that will do that cool so now that
we've got our web server built let's say
dot net
run
and we'll
um oh it looks like I haven't run.net
7.0 point the patch that came out
yesterday since the since yesterday
Okay so we've got our web server running
excellent let's come here to
localhost 5000. and we can see that our
web server is running this is cool now
if we pop open the developer tools and
reload it
we can see that this is giving us a 200
we've got the correct response headers
content type application Json let's type
in slash name equals
who and we can see that it's doing URL
parsing as well
that's pretty cool
so we took in this piece it's pulling
data out of our query string
automatically binding it to our
parameters outputting correctly
formatted Json and all of that in a
server that is
four lines of code
now that's pretty cool
um that's not the code that I wrote
yesterday though how did we get here I
remember the movement where we started
talking about visual Fred as we moved
from a regular from VB to vb.net and
we're like but but this is too weird
so let's take a step back and see how we
got here
so if I'm in visual studio and I wanted
to scaffold out a project that kind of
had that minimal API and got all the
files set up I did a new web API project
and there's this checkbox right here
that says use controllers I uncheck that
now I'm using minimal apis or I can
check that and now I'm using controllers
again and that'll just get me started
but in this website I've got
Net 5 website so we're going to see that
nice warning down here in the build
saying but but but it's not supported
anymore yeah
but we've got this.net 5 website and as
the website starts up we can see we have
a home page we've got an about page
we've got a API that'll show us weather
details we've got Swagger so that we can
try it out
let's click try it out and execute and
we can see that we've got some Json
results
now what's interesting about this
website is that we're actually using all
three paradigms of Hosting content
in.net
so here's our website
and we have a home controller
here's our home controller we have an
index view we can come into the views
folder and there's our index View and
here it says our home page so
typical.net 5 website
we rigged this up because here in
startup.cs we start off by saying add
controllers with views
and then down here at the bottom we say
map controller route
and that's what fires up asp.net
MVC to be able to detect those
controllers match them with the views
and everything works out great
what's interesting though is that's our
home page if we go to the about page the
about page actually uses razor pages
so Razer pages is excellent for being
able to map a particular URL to a page
we could think of this kind of like
classic ASP we don't want to do those
layers of indirection we just want to go
straight from a URL to a page so here's
our about page and that's working with
razor Pages we can see the pages folder
and the about
cshtml we've got Razer Pages well how
did we rig up Razer pages
here in the startup we can see that we
say dot add razor pages so that will go
scan our Razer Pages folder our Pages
folder we also have map razor pages and
now our Razer Pages light up
but we also have web API in this and
that's powering this weather forecast
controller and our Swagger page well how
did we rig that up well here's our
weather forecast controller that by the
way is a controller
because it's a controller here in our
startup.cs we said map controllers with
routes which nicely mapped all of our
web API controllers too that's excellent
and then we also added Swagger and we
added the Swagger UI now we chose to add
the Swagger UI only in development so
that if we publish it to production
those API endpoints are not as
discoverable that is definitely not a
security mechanism but we're kind of
using it to kind of Aid security a
little bit it's discoverable in
development it's not discoverable in
production
if we did want to change that if we did
want to make them discoverable we could
put those out here and now Swagger is
available in production as well
so we have all three paradigms we have
MVC we have razor pages and we have web
API
yeah in the new new
um
new project dialogue their check boxes
and we have to check one or the other
but they're just adding these lines and
so we've got all three of them
now I probably wouldn't use all three in
one project I would probably pick the
one that makes the most sense but I
wanted to show how we can upgrade a net
five project to.net seven and if you're
using any of these three paradigms which
are all of them then you're not going to
be left out so let's upgrade from.net5
to.net seven now we could definitely
come in here to the properties pop open
the property grid and do all the things
but what we're going to do to upgrade
from five to seven
change the number from five to seven
that's all the drop down does
welcome to.net seven we just upgraded
if that's all you do is upgrade
from.net5 to.net seven by changing the
number you will immediately see
performance benefits they've done a lot
in reducing allocations using span of T
it the framework is just faster
and so if you get nothing else come into
your project upgrade it from 3.1 to 5 to
7 from 5 to 7 from six to seven and you
will see performance benefits
okay let's take it a little bit further
I'm going to come in here and I'm going
to say manage can you get packages let's
see if there's some updates oh look
here's an updated package let's update
it yes
the scariest part of this demo
conference Wi-Fi it looks like that
package updated correctly and we can now
see the new number here
so we'll fire it up and now we have a
Net 7 website we upgraded our net core
3.1 or 5 or 6 website just by flipping
the number and updating nuget packages
and now we can see that the website is
going to work exactly as it did before
we've got an MVC page right here we've
got a Razer Pages page right here we've
got a web API page right here together
with the Swagger details
it all just works
cool any questions so far about
upgrading from.net to net seven
excellent now if you're going to stop
here that's totally fine but let's see
if we can push it further
now one of the things that is really
interesting here in let's pull up a home
controller
we start out by indenting four spaces
for our class we ended another four
spaces for our method we indent four
spaces I'm at 12 spaces in and I haven't
even said anything yet
okay we could change it from spaces to
tabs we could change it to less spaces
we can definitely have that argument but
by default I am 12 spaces in and I
haven't said anything yet
let's see if we can optimize that a
little bit
now one of the things that we notice is
that typically we have a namespace up at
the top
and then we never change it again
well if I have the entire file that sits
in a single namespace let's do the new
syntax and make it apply to the entire
file
now I just push semicolon there and vs
code visual studio just automatically
unindented it that far yes I realize I'm
about to change every line and every
file so git diff is now
um completely wrong but we've now got a
file scope namespace
now if I'm Auto generating code or if I
have a file that has multiple namespaces
in it I can still do it the old way
that's totally fine but if I like this
new style I'm now indenting only eight
spaces to get into my code that's kind
of cool
so let's do that let's come around to
all of our other namespaces and we will
indent them
using file scope namespaces there's one
there
there's one here
there's one here I never understood why
weather forecast wasn't in the models
folder but
okay
and now
let's go find all of the namespace lines
make sure I got all of them
yes excellent
and if we build this we can see that it
builds successfully
cool
now we could have definitely stopped
with just changing the file num the
version number but this is kind of cool
we've now taken some advantage of some
interesting things
next up
using statements
have you ever fought over a pull request
where the answer was you've got an extra
using statement you've got a using
statement you didn't sort the using
statements
I hate that
no just just accept my code I know I
didn't visual studio just automatically
generated I didn't even scroll up that
high in the file anyway just just make
that go away
we spend a lot of time fighting over
using statements and in fact Visual
Studio is about to tell me that I can
remove all of these and okay so maybe we
can have a build task that removes them
but then does it commit and yeah that's
a whole thing
so let's centralize all of our using
statements I'm going to add a new file
let's call this one usings.js
are usings
dot CS
and this won't be a class file instead
this will be a global usings file Global
using system
excellent anywhere in any code in this
project that needs to say using system
no longer needs to do that because this
applies to all of the files in my
project
so here inside of
um
weather forecast.cs where that's the
only using
it's now completely obsolete I can
remove it
and if we build
we can see that it still builds
successfully
cool I just moved all of those crazy
using statements from all of the files
into one spot so now we can argue about
just one thing let's remove and sort in
there so let's come through in all of
the rest of the files and let's come
grab all of our using statements and
we'll put them here in using.cs
and so let's go grab those
let's go grab these
and let's go grab
these
and let's go grab these
and I think there's one more
right here
oh that one doesn't have one cool so all
of these using statements I want to now
turn into Global using statements so a
little bit of regex let's find the
beginning of the line and let's add
Global dot into it
magic of regex that is really cool let's
now take out the double global
build
let's go find all of the using in my
code make sure I got them all
I did excellent
cool
now I love here in Visual Studio we get
the green squiggle saying up
I think you already did that one so
let's remove all of those here's some
and I could definitely use the shortcut
there but I'm gonna skip that one for
now let's delete these and this one and
this one
and these
and this
cool I have now 16 using statements for
my entire project
now if we have a library that has a
conflicting definition maybe especially
in testing the thing that defines it we
may want to specifically put that using
statement inside that file and we
definitely can
but we could also centralize all the
other ones let's create all of the
system dot whatevers and all the
microsoft.whatevers and all the our site
dot whatevers and put those here in this
Global using file that applies to all
things in our project now there's
nothing magic about this file name we
could have put it inside of the top of
program.cs we could have put an in a
file named Global we could put it
wherever we wanted it's just a file
now that's kind of interesting but this
is a website
and there's probably some
namespaces that get pulled in
automatically are some usings that most
projects might need to include now we
can tell from this project that it is a
website so could we just you know say
automatically import those things
let's come in here and let's say
implicit usings
enable
now if I created a new project in.net6
or net seven this would be in here
automatically but we upgraded a.net 5
project so it wasn't in here yet
now this implicit usings let's build
this again and then let's go looking
inside of our project I'm going to go
into this asp.net 5 folder because
that's the one we updated inside the
object folder
and let's go into.net7
and let's look for this file
site.globalusings.g.cs because we turned
on implicit usings this file gets
generated for us automatically
now the cool part about this file is
these are all of the usings that just
Auto magically get pulled in
so I'm going to set this at the top of
my code temporarily
and that will help me find all of the
green squiggles of things that are
already in there oh cool
all of these ones
this one this one
and now I can go delete all of these and
that'll be great
now this is interesting Global using
Global colon
this first one says that it's going to
apply to everything in the project
this one says that the namespace is a
global namespace what if I created a
file where I said
namespace site Dot
system
okay first off shame on me for doing so
but second off because I've created this
then a system no longer means what we
thought it did and so as a tribute to
making sure that this is actually really
the top of the namespace tree it says
Global colon colon
so yeah we could go run around in our
usings and do that too but I'll just
make the assumption that we're not being
dumb about namespaces and just leave it
cool
all of the usings in all of the files in
this entire project are now right there
all six of them
can we stop fighting about this in PRS
now
please
yeah now we fight about exactly one file
should I delete this one line
sure okay fight's over
we're done that's cool all of the usings
from our project now are centralized in
one place and we don't have to worry
about it in our code trimming the back
out adding them back in if we want to
grab a specific library that may only
apply to one file and we don't want this
particular Import in all of the rest of
the files we can definitely put it at
the top of that file and that totally
makes sense but in the majority of the
case we'll probably put them here inside
This Global usings file
and if we start up our website we can
see that it still works just fine
we've used file scope namespaces we've
used Global usings we've used implicit
usings and MVC web API or razor pages
and web API all still work great
any questions so far
yep
most Ides usually Auto add musings to
your file can you configure The Ides to
add them to your Global good question so
a lot of Ides are going to automatically
put our usings at the top of the file
can we get it to put in in our Global
file
I haven't found a way to do that there
is no convention on what that file name
is and so I totally get that you know it
could go look for
the file but there is no the file it's
whatever we chose to name it and
wherever we chose to put it and it might
be in multiple files so visual studio is
kind of like
I don't know
so yeah it is unfortunate and we'll see
that in a bit where it puts it at the
top and that may not be exactly where we
want it yeah
I'm not worried
but yeah we're gonna fight about that in
a PR instead
great question thanks any other
questions right here
yep
can I use an alias with the usings yes I
can
the cool part is I can also use the
other usings where I specifically grab
the static name and make all of the
functions available without a class name
that's available in global usings as
well
that does sound terrifying where did
this function come from uh I don't know
yeah Okay so we've got file scoped
usings
let's take advantage of the new Builder
now right here here in program.cs we
have kind of an interesting thing going
on now as uh developers we always look
for public static void main that's kind
of the initiation of all the things and
here in public static void main we
create this host Builder we dot build
dot run
what's this host Builder
um I don't know I think that's Latin for
um
bootstrap this startup file
it feels like that entire file is
useless all it's saying is startup is
over there
here in startup we have nice sections
that we can understand better we've got
this configure Services where it sets up
the ioc container we've got configure
where it defines the pipeline here's
where magic starts to happen
let's take advantage of the new Builder
though and get rid of this whole create
host Builder thing that thing is just
Mayhem
bye-bye
VAR Builder equals web
application.createbuilder
now we can pass in our command line
arguments that'll be helpful for if we
have any overrides on the command line
it's still going to pick up our app
config our app settings.config and it'll
still pick up environment variables but
picking up command line arguments is
interesting too
now we'll
set up ioc container
and then let's say VAR app equals
Builder dot build
and then we'll set up our request
pipeline
and then let's say app.run
cool
as a developer looking for static void
main to try and find out how my app
works that's a lot more understandable
to me
now we still need to do these steps so
set up ioc container well it's currently
in startup.cs so let's say VAR startup
equals new startup and it takes in a
configuration Builder dot configuration
excellent
then let's set up the ROC container
startup Dot
configure Services it takes in
nothing
nope it takes in services so let's send
in Builder dot services and we're set up
request pipelines startup dot configure
it takes in an app and an environment
cool
now if we like that separation between
program and startup we can definitely
stop here because
otherwise this method might get this
class might get a little long but that's
kind of the basics of how we set up our
web server but I want to take it a
little bit farther I don't really like
this separation between program and
startup so I'm going to go grab these
configure Services details and I'm going
to set it right here inside of program
let's put it right there
now we don't have a Services we could
say VAR Services equals
builder.services that definitely works
but
I'm going to go the other direction and
I'm just going to say
builder.services all the things
and there's actually a simpler way to do
Swagger gen I could just leave all of
that off too if I wanted to get extra
spiffy but yeah I'll leave that in
when I create a new asp.net 7 project it
will actually not have this piece which
is kind of cool
okay let's now go grab our request
pipeline so here's all of the pieces
there let's remove that from there and
set it in here
which by the way means that we yeah we
can get rid of the endpoints too thank
you vs
let's say app.map controller and app.map
racer pages
and
now we can just get rid of this startup
thing all together
goodbye startup
delete
now there is one more spot here in
program.cs where it needs NV okay app
dot environment
cool
and we can build our app and we can see
that everything starts up just fine
cool
now that's fun we've kind of extracted
away all of the Mayhem of what is public
static void main doing and we can even
take this a step farther and the cool
part is that this works here for
program.cs the unfortunate part is it
only works here for program.cs it does
not work for any other files in our
solution but we can say
let's just remove that whole
class and Method thing
and because it's program.cs we can
assume that it is the public static void
main method and then here's just the
contents of that method
where did args come from
yeah we can argue about whether this is
better or worse but it's definitely
possible and that's cool
and this will build just fine
we now have taken advantage of that new
Builder and we can kind of get more
pieces in here to kind of Define all of
the specifics now if we're both razor
pages and web API and MVC we've been
able to upgrade our project from.net5
to.net6 and take advantage of these new
c-sharp 10 and 11 features
any questions so far
yep
can we use async here in the program CS
yes we can
um
none of these methods are async but yes
top level async and await works just
fine here great question
so this is a minimal api's talk and we
haven't done minimal API in yet
let's do that
so
here is MVC here's Razer Pages let's do
this app dot map get now we can't do the
home page because that's actually going
to our home controller so let's say API
slash minimal
and I'm going to Route it to this
function here new
message equals hello
and let's say name let's grab name
String name and we will make it optional
nullable reference types is awesome
we could specifically say this is from
query string or from body but it's
implied so we'll just leave it that way
hello name and we'll give it a default
of world and let's give it an ID of I
don't know three
and here is this minimal API
cool we mapped get to this function
together with web API together with MVC
together with Razer Pages it's just
another mechanism that we can use we now
have a fourth Paradigm for building web
servers
cool so we did map get could we do some
more stuff let's say app.map post now I
want to play with
attribute routing here so I'm going to
say this is one
two
and that will give me two parameters
and so I'll say string one and int 2.
and let's do some interesting things
with that return a new
um
message
that is one and an ID of two
uh comma there you go
cool
so we get attribute routing in the same
way that we had attribute routing with
controllers it just works it'll go pick
out those parameters and set them into
place in our method to be able to pull
in those details
now I could give it some more validation
about you know make sure that it
actually isn't in to make sure it's
positive I could do other things in
there with attribute routing perhaps I
make this one optional and this one
optional you know I could definitely do
that too oh and it's saying hey
can you like do that
cool
so now I've got a post what about a put
app
Dot
map put and here I'll just do API slash
minimal but here I want to do a little
bit more in My Method let's say I'd like
to
um
dues take in an object
uh I'll actually even say this uses a
route
um
and let's do some validation
bull valid in this case it is true
let's take in another object
and now if it wasn't valid
then we want to say return this Dot
bad request
and then we'll save and then we'll
return this Dot okay
cool
that works out great
almost
in a controller we're really used to
saying this dot or maybe we're just
pulling it out of the controller and so
this refers to the controller
well what does this refer to here
it refers to
this method
now this Lambda doesn't have a bad
request thing on it it doesn't have an
okay thing on it so how do we do
these how do we return interesting
status codes
well we can do response
is it response
results
dot whatever
and so here in results we have this
object go to definition that can give us
lots of different things so status 403
Forbidden here's a forbid async here's a
sign in async here's a
Content async all of the ones that we
had are here inside of results and they
return an i result interface
so we could choose to implement this I
result interface
and do our own things
so one of the things I like to do is to
be able to send a status code and a Json
result
and so we have a status code result and
we have a Json body result but we don't
have one that is both so I spin up a new
thing I'll defend I'll descend from I
result and now I've defined my task that
does interesting things so that's how we
do kind of larger methods here
well let's clean this up a little bit I
want to create a new model I'll call
this a
minimal model
and
um
it will have public int ID
public string message
and public minimal model optional of
data
yeah I could definitely do a record and
that would be interesting I'll make
message required so I need to Define it
to a value and now we have our minimal
model so now that we've got our minimal
model let's come back here to our
program.cs and now we can do some
interesting things because I'm returning
a minimal model
I can now take in a minimal model and
um
now I need to play the
Caps game because I was just returning
lowercase things but now we've got kind
of more established pieces
cool
all the things that we can do inside of
controllers we can now do inside of web
API inside of minimal apis
any questions right here
great question so how do I prevent the
baddies from getting in can I do
authorization
now what I would love to be able to do
is to say something like
ah
authorized here because that would feel
a lot like a controller
and that's not how it works
so do I put it
here
no that's not how it works either
because you know here it's the map put
method and that's not really so the way
we do it is we do it like this
require authorization now now it
requires somebody to be logged in I
could in the same way that I pass in
other things into the authorized
attribute I can pass in details here
about what role or claims you need or I
can be able to even invoke a method to
be able to pull your user identity and
do interesting things so in short yes
you can validate authorization in the
same way you do with controllers
great question
any other questions right here
yep
how do I do dependency injection good
point so I want to be able to take in my
data context in here now up here
somewhere I'm going to say
Builder dot Services dot add transient
and I'm going to give it some I think to
thing
or perhaps I have my data context and
now I want to here take in
and I thing
and it'll just pull in just fine
I could attribute it very specifically
in the same way that I could say here
this is from query it's actually not
it's from the API I can say from body
or I can say from
ioc from from services and so I'll put
this one as from services to make sure
that you don't accidentally inject some
post-body content that happens to
include something that kind of matches
my interface and I end up taking yours
instead of the one that I configured
previously but that's how we do
dependency injection is we just
specify it as a parameter inside of our
method that's cool
Okay so we've got this minimal API and
how do we test it
I'm going to save this project I'll pull
out my I thing so that I don't do bad
things later
and
let's open up the testing project
now here inside of our solution we've
just been live coding all the stuff we
started out with the.net 5 project we
upgraded it.net seven file scope
namespaces Global usings implicit gloves
we'll be using the new Builder minimal
apis we added a little bit more
structure and now let's take a look at
testing just to save us a little bit of
time I added a new project my test
project in this case I'm using X unit
but we could definitely use nunit or Ms
test or anything else as well
now I want to write a unit test around
this weather forecast controller
now this weather forecast controller
returns some random data
and I could take a little bit more
control over that by adding a layer of
indirection maybe I need a random
repository that will give me things but
uh
let's just assume that
I just want to check that I have five
results
okay so here's my weather unit test I'm
going to do the arrange act assert
pattern
and so I'm just going to call the method
I'm going to call the get method on my
controller I'm going to get an
innumerable weather forecast I will
validate that it should not be null and
then it has five items I could
definitely check for more things but
that's enough
now one of the libraries that I really
like is fluent assertions and here's why
I had here
int expected equals five and I said
assert Dot
equal
expected actual oh wait no actual comes
first
um wait no expected comes first and my
code compiles either way
I spent the longest time debugging the
test and I'm like
it's supposed to be seven I get seven
it passes wait no it says it should have
been five
and it was because I had expected an
actual flipped so one of the things that
I really love about fluent assertions
expected dot should dot do the thing and
here's my uh our actual dot should dot
do the thing and here's my expected
that's cool
so the majority of my assertions
actually say actual Dot
should dot equal expected and that's the
majority of my things so here I could
say expected and here I could rename
this to actual and now it's really clear
what is happening and
um
now I I can very specifically identify
this the other thing that I did part of
fluent assertions
um
is this assertion scope now the cool
thing is with assertion scope it's going
to run all of my tests
and it will show me all the failures
have you ever done this where the build
fails
and it fails on the first assertion in
your thing and so you go fix it and you
kick off the build and then it fails on
the next one
and then the next one
the cool part about assertion scope is
it will run all of them give me all of
the errors and now I can debug it in one
go make all of them pass and then commit
it I avoid all of those repeats
now there is one other interesting thing
here in this when I want a weather
forecast controller it takes in a logger
I don't care what that logger is that's
not part of my test my test is
validating that I have five results not
that I log correctly so I don't care
just just make it go away
well since it's unused I could make it
go away like this
and I'm going to choose not to do that
instead back here in our unit test I'm
going to create a new mock this is from
moq or Machu or Mock and I'm going to
take a mock of that eye logger of thing
and it will give me this logger I can
then create that new weather forecast
controller passing in that
implementation of it and it's just going
to return null or blank or the default
for anything that I call and just make
sure that that object exists
and now I have my weather forecast
controller and I can call controller.get
or I can take it a step further and I
can use automocker now the cool thing
about automocker is that it's going to
go automatically do the thing it's
dependency injection for tests
so I go create a new automocker I create
an instance of this thing and it will go
fill in all of the details of all of the
dependencies that I didn't need to
specify or I can very specifically
create a mock and implement the things
that I want and so that is actually
really beautiful so in this case I
create an automocker and I say hey
marker go create me that weather
forecast controller and for all those
things that I don't care about
I don't care just go figure it out
if ever you add a dependency to a
controller and you have to run around to
all your tests creating a new mock
automocker will do that for me I no
longer need to change my tests
that's just amazingly cool so we've got
this controller now we'll go call that
method and then away it goes
now that's great for unit testing we've
done this forever how would we do
integration testing well here in
integration testing we need to well
start up the web server oh wait we need
to go find an available Port so let's go
find an available Port that one's not in
use okay so let's go find a random Port
let's start up our web server now we
need to get that port number into our
client now we need to create a request
there's all of this Mayhem kind of going
on to be able to do an integration test
this is cool
I can create an integration test where I
create this new fixture that just does
interesting things now this won't
actually go out to do Network requests
but it will
instantiate my server and do the full
request pipeline it's all in memory it's
not over the network but it will do all
of the things that my server needs to do
now this is cool I have this web
application Factory of the program class
my program.cs that we built here I can
choose to override things so I need to
start by taking my thing out of the ioc
container and then I can put in a fake
one say my in-memory database
or let me swap the connection string off
to a connection string that is a test
file database that I just Implement for
this thing so I'll remove all the
services I don't need I'll add the fake
services in that I do need and now here
in my test
I have an instance of my application
that is effectively running
I now create an HTTP client from that
and now I have a client that works the
way I use HTTP client anywhere else so
let's do a network request to API
weather forecast we'll read the string
as async yeah I could definitely do read
Json async but in this case I kind of
wanted to do it the manual way let's
deserialize that into a list of weather
forecasts it's optional because I might
not have that body here and then I'll do
the assertion scope and I should have
five weather forecasts there
cool
now there is one more piece it's going
to be a little bit mad at me it's going
to say
um
argument
null exception dot throw if null
weather forecasts
name of weather forecast and the reason
that it does that is that C sharp going
to check the nullable reference types is
doesn't know that this should not be
null is doing that too so yeah I have to
go add one more check this will this
line will never get cut never get
executed it will never throw here it
can't but now the c-sharp compiler that
looks for nullable reference types will
be happy to
okay so in the same way that we did this
integration test we can do an
integration test of our minimal API
so we'll pass in name of test
and then we expect that body to be hello
test that's how it forms it
now why is the ID3
because I hard-coded it that way
ideally we would pass in something else
but yep that's how we can test our
minimal API we'll just fire a request at
it we'll get the response we'll
deserialize it and we'll do the things
similar let's go test our post we'll go
fire up a post body we'll send that off
to our minimal API and we'll grab the
response there
so let's build it
and of course our build is going to fail
why did the build fail the build failed
because
program is inaccessible
yes here in our program.cs we have an
auto generate all the things and that's
great but
by default it makes a private class
now we could definitely do internals
visible to we could you know try and
create a friend assembly and that gets
really weird or it actually creates a
partial private class so let's define
the other half of the partial class
tada
and now it builds
that is such a hack
I hate this this is awful this this hack
is just nasty so of course I'm going to
comment it
public for testing
and now it's a little bit less painful
um yes it's a hack I wish it created it
public by default but it doesn't I
understand why it doesn't but yeah if I
want to test it I need to make it public
cool so now let's start to fire up all
our tests I'll come here to the test
Explorer I happen to have it right here
and it is Tiny
so let's take a look at our tests and
let's run all of our tests one of the
things that I like while we're here in
the test Explorer is that I can come in
here and I can say
run tests on after every build now if my
tests are pretty fast then that's great
I can just anytime I build it'll fire up
my tests I can see if I'm succeeding or
failing live unit testing is a thing and
this isn't it but this is really nice if
my tests are fast that's cool
now in this case my tests aren't but all
four of our tests are passing I didn't
need to figure out ports I didn't need
to start up a server I didn't need to
kill it at the end I just said hey go go
fire up the thing HTTP client that I'm
already familiar with my tests work
great
any questions so far on testing
yep
is there a particular benefit to using
that over the exclamation operator good
question so here I said
I would like to throw
um if null could I have instead used the
null coalescing operator and just said
no really it isn't
is there a benefit or drawback from that
I like to use the
um null coalescing operator as the last
resort it's like this feels like I'm
telling the compiler that it was wrong
in the most most cases
I'm actually wrong and so I try to use
that as sparingly as possible is that
more or less legible
um
I tend to miss that
I read the first couple of characters in
the variable name and I think uh and so
I won't see this but I will see this and
so I would argue that this is more well
self-documenting
I tend to code for legibility and so I
prefer that is it better or worse it's a
preference thing
and if your preference is the other way
then that's great
what's the difference beyond what you
could read is there a notable difference
not that I know of
yeah great question any other questions
right here
yep
IED to
skip or get family authentication to um
so you can test your professors good
question so if I have to do
authentication stuff can I skip the
authentication for my tests now there's
kind of two sides to this the one side
is yeah if I skip authentication for my
tests am I really validating that the
entire site works and so maybe I need to
first hit the login page and or the
login API and get my Json web token my
jot and then pass that into the other
test that could be one way to go or here
we're saying
um what is the environment and right now
the environment is development so I
could say in my authentication mechanism
but in development don't authenticate
now at that point we lose all of the
user context so maybe we're saying if
the environment is test run and now in
test run my authentication is disabled
and I could definitely do that instead
yeah that was awesome
any other questions right here
Okay so we've got our tests and this is
working out well I'm going to go back to
our other app that doesn't have tests
and continue on there
uh why yes let's save all of that
now we might have I don't know half a
dozen models in our thing we probably
have four methods per model and uh of
course I'm going to put all of my stuff
at the bottom and you're going to put
all of your stuff at the bottom and so
we're going to end up with these merge
conflicts where the merge starts to
zipper our methods together
and of course I don't want to deal with
that any more than you do so I'm going
to take mine and you're going to take
yours and and our code is gone
hmm can we like make this a little
better
I'm going to
take all of this out here and let's just
make up a convention I will create a new
folder called apis I'll create a new
class I'll call this minimal
dot CS
file scope namespaces are awesome
and let's say
let's make a
get method
public
minimal model
get that
let's make a post method
so let's go grab this and we'll say
public minimal model
post
there is that
we'll grab this and we'll make a put
method
public eye result response
put
and we'll do that we no longer need this
oh it's not I response it's I results
oh hey we need to using
oh no it's just mad
I result it is singular
cool and then I don't know let's invent
this method public void in it let's take
in an eye application or a web
application
we'll call this app
and
then let's map get to the get method
and let's map post to the post method
and let's map put to the put method
and now let's come back over here into
program.cs
and I will say VAR
uh minimal equals new minimal
and minimal
dot init and pass in app
or oh I need a using statement
thank you but I would like this in my
Global usings please
I wish it did that automatically but
back here now this
um I don't really want to new this so
I'm going to say app dot Services dot
get required service of type minimal and
I'll just yank it for my
iocontainer.init app and I could make
that an extension method and now it's
one line so okay now we were fighting
over the merge conflict now my merge and
your merge they're one line it'll
probably make them separate and I think
that's okay
foreign
what does this look like
it looks like a controller
why don't I just well I don't know
use a controller we've gotten to the
illogical conclusion of minimal apis
let's presume that we have half a dozen
models we have four methods each we're
going to do all of this Mayhem we may as
well just use web API this is not the
right tool for the job we have gone too
far
minimal apis is great for small problems
if we have Enterprise applications with
lots of models and lots of methods web
API is right there it's not deprecated
let's use that instead
instead let's take a look at what The
Right Use case for minimal apis would be
so I'm going to close this solution and
let's open up this project right here
the right size
now here in the right size project I
have this interesting Json file and my
task is to put this online
that's it
or accept a form post and send an email
or accept a web hook and and alter the
data in some way I just need to do this
one little thing I just need this online
this is the right size for a minimal API
now the cool thing here is that in this
project I have exactly one c-sharp file
it's this program.cs and that's all
I happen to have a few Json files
kicking around they aren't necessary I
could definitely delete them but that's
fine
let's pop open program.cs
now here in program.cs I create a
builder
I add some stuff to my ioc container I'm
going to go read that interesting config
file and I'm going to then deserialize
it into the strongly typed object I
defined a record down here record class
the interesting config and so now it's a
strongly typed deserialization I'll
throw if it's null and then I'll add it
to my ioc container now I chose to put
it in curly braces right here just so
that I can't cheat and just grab the
thing straight out of the other file I
want to definitely leverage my ioc
container
app.build and now if you call this
endpoint I'm going to go grab that
interesting config and I'm going to
return it
so
let's fire up this website
now here's this website we've got
Swagger on it that's awesome let's try
it out and we get our interesting config
cool
now as any good endpoint we also
probably want to handle not found pages
so not a valid page
here and here's our 404 page we probably
also want to do error handling so let's
go to error and we get a 500 error we
also probably want to do some health
checks
so let's go to the health checks
all best practices with a service how
did we do that well we wanted to rig our
404 page so we're going to go grab star
meaning anything else so go grab the
rest of the URL and let's map it to this
not found page now originally I just had
this as blank and so I got Chrome's
default page was saying hey there's
nothing here
and I wanted to say yeah let me share
with some content I thought it was my
network connection so I returned not
found
I want to map the error page to result
stop problem
now I chose to map the errors to the
error page so any error that happens in
my application will naturally land on
this page how did we do health checks
well I say dot add health checks and I
map health checks to the health URL so
now if kubernetes notices that my
container isn't returning this 200 on my
health page it knows that my container
is probably unhealthy and it can
automatically restart it that's perfect
all of this in 46 lines of code
including that hack to make this app
testable
this is the right size for minimal apis
if we need to upgrade to have dozens of
models then web API is right there and
we don't want to deprecate it it's still
right there it's a great solution if we
want to upgrade to having even less
details about it Azure functions or
k-native functions are right there and
we can leverage that
for those small problems where we want
to take control over the hdb request and
we want to just do something real fast
we can upgrade to minimal apis
web API MVC razor pages and now minimal
apis we now have four paradigms for
building websites inside of asp.net and
as we can see in this app they will all
play nicely together
use the correct one for the job and you
can accomplish great things minimal apis
is right here and the code for all of
this including that correct solution is
up here on GitHub right now
thanks for coming